the secret the the skeleton key to all
of design is learning proportions and I
don't know how else to do it a better
way to do it and then to learn
cartography so here I'm gonna take
resonate the title the publication the
subtitle the journal for graphic design
in january/february to show you how to
use lines to group and to separate how
to draw emphasis two things
so the first one is really easy all I'm
going to do is take that text I'm put on
one line across here I'll zoom in so you
guys can see this a little bit better
and I've just anchored everything on one
horizontal line which is this one and I
could do variations on this now I can
repeat the line and do one on the top
and one on the bottom I've changed it to
be half like this is four points and
this is two points in thickness the
reason why I do that is I'm still
obeying the law of contrast where if
you're going to use a different point
size we suggest that you double the
point size or more so instead of using
36 point type and 42 point type we would
say you use 36 and 72 point so if I use
two rules don't make one four point and
one three point seven points it doesn't
make any sense
it'll look like a mistake so it's half
as thick as this line here's another
example and the reason why I showed you
this is because as I was scanning the
different layouts I saw like certain
themes emerge and people were designing
in a very specific way but they weren't
using lines as tools to aid in
communication and to guide the eye so I
just want to show you some very basic
things to do with lines that are
functional not decorative okay so here
the same line exists but this time it's
including a little line going vertically
and this is a divider so the bottom line
anchors these two groups of information
together but this little vertical line
says this is the date and this is kind
of cool because over time this could
change to March April and now we know
this is a variable that will change but
this is constant this piece of
information constant this is variable so
we're both grouping and dividing here
these are such good lessons Chris thank
you for saying that so here we have
basically two lines one to anchor the
two pieces information but one to draw
emphasis and they serve different
functions there and if you take a look
at that kind of looks modern it's kind
of cool
so you probably sitting there thinking
okay everything that we can do with
lines and shapes for these two pieces of
information is done but you would be
mistaken my friend because we're going
to keep going so here's another way to
use now a shape and and this was asked
in typography class when I was still a
student at Art Center what's the
difference between a rule and a shape
what a certain point the line becomes so
thick we stopped reading it as a line
and we just call it a shape and it's one
of those things like like I'll know it
when I see it because at a certain point
you could say and you can argue that's
the shape and I wouldn't be able to
argue with you so here this big black
box draws our eye towards resonate the
journal for graphic design it gives it a
lot of importance because of the maximal
amount of ink and contrast that we're
creating and this tiny little bracket
here since yeah but we're related we
know each other we came to this party
together yet very organized and that's
the beauty of it it's kind of that Swiss
modern kind of organizational thing that
I really enjoy and like and so I hope to
introduced you to some of this visual
language that you can incorporate in
your design work yeah yeah very powerful
okay so here's another way I don't love
this one but there are three vertical
lines repetition remember it's all
consonants and dissonance repetition and
contrast and so these three things they
know because this is only one story hi
and this is two stories high well by
doing as we group these things together
these same principles apply to almost
every kind of design and the one that I
could relate to most is architectural
you'll see that there's a little window
or doorway to the right here but it's
still enclosed in this structure and
it's pretty cool okay I made this one
dotted just to show you doesn't have to
be filled in because they separate but
our eye can travel through the empty
spaces here's another way of using the
line to tie information together so in
this case I made the date align
vertically centered
little dot there just through the stroke
right so if you go to the stroke panel
it's right there
you can choose different arrows and two
doodads and fingers and all kinds of
things but just a little circle so that
gives it a little visual weight and
emphasis nice keep going so in this case
I'm treating this like it's a piece of
paper hmm it has its own shape it can
block things it can intersect with
things it can be rotated you can do lots
of different things but right now I just
offset that a little bit so they're
grouped but separate again lots of
things you can do here and we can get
really crazy and I'll show you what I
mean right now so if I take this and
then I put it on top it creates another
feeling I want to show you that to you
and I put it behind it creates a
different feeling
it creates depth right so there's a lot
of things that you can do so if I line
up right there let's just say that was a
line and now the ease impossible to read
but nice these are things that you guys
can play with and you should play with
them to figure out what works and what
doesn't work same two boxes this time
stacked one on top of each other one in
verse and it crazy had another feeling
and generally speaking I didn't do this
but if you want to repeat the
measurement here it should be the same
and then you offset it and you're gonna
see this a lot in architecture for
example imagine if this were the first
storey of the building this is second
storey of the building and this is an
empty space so it's cantilevered over it
if we're looking at the elevation
looking at a building as for standing on
the street looking at it and you look at
he'll say oh that's really cool and
modern all I did they were they took
shapes on the offset it and you can see
a lot of the modern buildings
skyscrapers they'll take this and
they'll offset it and they'll rotate
each floor a little bit differently and
that creates a deck a roof deck or
something like that it's pretty cool if
you look at some of the work from Ginza
you'll see things like this same ideas
being applied over and over again all
right Chris we should put a clasp on
that I like to sign up for it what class
might that be tell me the time it takes
your / typography cool great yeah yeah
believe it or not I've actually designed
buildings before exteriors and interiors
based on the same principles that I'm
sharing with you today all right and
I've had the pleasure of working in many
different design projects not just
two-dimensional but three-dimensional
one of my clients actually hired us to
design the facade of a building and it
was really cool to be able to do that
nice why I've said many times before the
secret to all of a design is learning
proportions and I don't know how else to
do it a better way to do it and then to
learn photography I've used the same
thing to design a floor plan for my
office to design furniture from my space
and to design buildings for clients
facades okay it's not not a structural
engineering but yeah the last one I
wanted to show you here is an open box
so I just delete at the top of the box
and put it here and it kind of feels
like it's balanced on this little thing
right so it creates a different feeling
and you can keep layering you can do
different things with this so if I fill
this box with white I'm gonna do that
right now
and I were to take a shape and do
something like this and I'm gonna fill
the shape with a pattern let's say I
want to fill it with this kind of
pattern and get rid of these stroke and
I'm sent it to the back there in
nineteen eighties yeah this is the whole
Memphis design style Anoka yeah April
crimen era she might call us later and
say oh there you are
so like little registration marks uh how
awesome is that
and then now we're now we're cooking
with gas as they say
so here I've taken the mass at resonate
I've done the same thing I've anchored
it with a strong like Milkha would call
this the spine a strong baseline
something to anchor all these components
together and then I've cut it off so
we're seeing the head and not the feet I
love that analogy and then the journal
for graphic design tucked underneath it
separated about a couple things but also
with this little vertical stroke that
that creates a tee to say like we're
done there's no more information beyond
the stop here so I doesn't have to keep
looking to the right it's a strong
stopping point and a way to kind of
finish the sign
if you're enjoying these critiques
inspired by the work you see and want to
get better at layout and design for
print web film or television we have a
course available on our site that is
designed just for you it will help you
to learn the rules of typography how to
create contrast control focal points
achieve asymmetrically beautiful layouts
how to critique your own work keyboard
shortcuts and include my personal tips
on how to build an asset library so you
can design at the speed of thought
as an added bonus students who enrolled
in the course can participate in future
critiques get updates as a release them
and a time-lapse video of me working on
layouts not available anywhere else you
can jump in anytime work at your own
pace and take your typography skills to
the next level that's it for me I hope
to see you in the future
[Music]
[Applause]
you